[Musik]
die flucht liegt hinter ihnen wie es
weitergeht ungewiss allein hier am
berliner hauptbahnhof kommen jeden tag
tausende menschen aus der ukraine an
wir sind in odessa los das war am 4 märz
wir sind quer durch die ganze ukraine
gereist erst nach liszts dann rüber nach
polen nach warschau und jetzt sind wir
endlich hier
wir haben vier tage lang nur gestanden
um herzukommen
für mich war es irgendwie wichtig etwas
auszurichten und all den menschen die an
kommen mit kriegserfahrungen irgendwie
etwas zu geben ein herzliches willkommen
zu heißen ihn irgendwie ein bisschen
wärme zu geben die hilfsbereitschaft in
deutschland ist groß herzlich willkommen
zu einem zdf spezial
über die lage der flüchtlinge berichten
wir gleich jetzt aber erst mal der blick
in die ukraine präsident selensky sieht
sein land mittlerweile auf dem
siegeskurs
gleichzeitig meldet der
vize-bürgermeister von mario pohl
zerstörungen wie in grosny oder aleppo
die stadt existiere eigentlich nicht
mehr astra gardot mit einem überblick
seit zehn tagen ist die stadt unter
beschuss und nicht mehr wiederzuerkennen
die bewohner von mario pohl geiseln in
ihrer eigenen stadt der angriff gestern
verheerend diese frau hat die
bombardierungen fast unversehrt
überstanden
weiter oben im selben gebäude wird ein
junge aus dem schutt begraben er lebt
für andere kommt jede hilfe zu spät und
es gibt kein entkommen die sogenannten
flucht korridore sind unter beschuss die
überlebenden wissen oft nicht wohin ich
habe kein zuhause mehr
deshalb bin ich hier unterwegs warum
sollte ich sonst hier rumlaufen
laut ukrainischen behörden hat es in den
letzten 24 stunden keine gebietsverluste
an russische truppen gegeben trotz
heftiger gefechte und angriffe auf immer
mehr städte in
der nacht auf freitag hat das
bombardierungen bis weit in den westen
gegeben bis nach iwano frankiwsk südlich
von lemberg und die russischen truppen
rücken vor immer weiter ins landesinnere
neue satellitenbilder zeigen der
kilometerlange russische konvoi vor der
hauptstadt kiew ist aufgelöst und wie
diese heute veröffentlichten bilder des
russischen verteidigungsministeriums
zeigen sollen sind die panzer auf dem
weg in ihr einsatzgebiet kiew in den
kurzen feuerpausen versuchen die
bewohner die stadt zu verlassen doch
zerstörte brücken und straßen blockieren
die wege hinaus in das vermeintlich
sichere umland zweieinhalb millionen
ukrainer sind derzeit auf der flucht die
meisten versuchen sich im südwesten in
sicherheit zu bringen und in polen rund
anderthalb millionen ukrainer sind
bereits dort angekommen die
zurückgebliebenen harren weiter aus in u
bahn schächten und kellern wie in der
heftig umkämpften stadt nicolais dort im
untergrund richtet irina einen
verzweifelten appell ganz persönlich an
putin
mein herr rufen sie ihre truppen zurück
lassen sie uns ein normales leben leben
wir können hier kaum noch atmen wegen
ihrer bomben wenn sie schon kein mitleid
mit unseren soldaten haben dann
wenigstens mit uns es ist genug
die erschreckende bilanz seit beginn des
krieges sind laut un mer ukrainische
zivilisten getötet worden als soldaten
über die militärische lage sprechen wir
mit dem ehemaligen nato general egon
ramms genannt
ramms in einer fernsehansprache hat der
ukrainische präsident gesagt die ukraine
habe einen strategischen wendepunkt der
reis gegenüber den russen ist da was
dran oder dient das nur dazu den
durchhaltewillen zu stärken
ich denke ist es beides gemeint einmal
den durchhaltewillen der ukrainischen
streitkräfte und der ukrainischen
bevölkerung auf der einen seite auf der
anderen seite kann die ukraine aber für
sich in anspruch nehmen dass sie am 16
ist immer noch in den neuesten stellung
hält auch wenn sie offensichtlich jetzt
wieder stärker unter russischen druck
gerät wie beurteilen sie denn die
positionen der russischen truppen
aktuell
also es hat fortschritte gegeben im
osten ist hat fortschritte gegeben im
süden und im norden beziehungsweise
umkehr frau müssen wir damit rechnen
dass die umgruppierung auch dieser
kolonne die ja lange tage im zentrum der
berichterstattung gestanden hat dazu
führen wird dass auch diese kräfte
soweit sie noch einsatzfähig sind in den
angriff mit eingezogen werden dafür
spricht auch das artilleriegeschütz von
diesen kräften nähe von kiew in stellung
gebracht worden sind
die amerikaner sind ja sehr besorgt dass
russland chemie waffen einsetzen könnte
ist das aus ihrer sicht ein
realistisches szenario
also sie haben vorhin erwähnt aleppo und
sie haben großen hier erwähnt mit den
grossen zerstörung auch beim kampf gegen
die zivilbevölkerung und in aleppo das
dürfen wir nicht vergessen hat russland
ja auch den einsatz von chemiewaffen von
salat in syrien unterstützt von daher
wäre das durchaus eine möglichkeit was
ich pervers finde im augenblick ist die
tatsache dass der un sicherheitsrat zu
diesem thema tagt und die russen dort
ohne beweise die wir vorgelegt haben
diese behauptung versuchen zu erhärten
und damit versuchen den
weltsicherheitsrat ja eigentlich ein
gremium welches für die sicherheit in
der ganzen welt sorgen soll dafür zu
instrumentalisieren das ist schon ein
bisschen pervers was erwarten sie jetzt
für die kommenden tage
also ich rechne damit dass die russen
versuchen werden ihren druck weiter zu
verstärken insbesondere um kiew
einzuschließen und raum gewinne zu
machen denn bisher ist im sechzehnten
kampftag der furcht in die russen haben
wollten nicht eingetreten und das dürfte
auch auf den präsidentenstuhl lenski
zurückzukommen auch der grund sein warum
er von einem wendepunkt gesprochen hat
aber hier bleibt abzuwarten wie sich
diese lage weiter entwickelt und wie
weit russland noch in der lage ist neue
kräfte einzuführen um den druck auf die
ukrainische streitkräfte zu erhöhen wenn
ich da vielleicht noch einen satz zu dem
thema zivilbevölkerung ich finde das was
dort passiert in den städten mit den
eingeschlossenen städten der bombardier
und der zivilbevölkerung finde ich
fürchterlich aber auch da gelten die
bilder wie wir sie in grosny und aleppo
gesehen haben
apropos eingeschlossene städte sehen sie
auch den versuch der russen den ring um
wichtige städte kiel von odessa
beispielsweise zu schließen denn jetzt
inzwischen schon bald erfolgreich
also bei kiew ist das sehr schwierig zu
beurteilen weil kiew ja auch von den
ukrainischen streitkräfte und auch von
vielen bürgern der ukraine nachhaltig
verteidigt wird bisher der ring muss
insbesondere ich sage dass man im
südwesten geschlossen werden dort ist er
offensichtlich noch in teilen offen ob
den russen das gelingt das eine
vorhersehbarkeit die ich so im
augenblick nicht sehe
wobei man bei diesen informationen dann
auch immer vorsichtig sein muss mit
einer konkreten lage beurteilen weil man
nicht weiß was an kräften noch zur
verfügung steht vielen dank egon ramms
gerne herzlichen dank
wie geht es den menschen in der ukraine
wie erleben sie diesen alltag im krieg
auf der flucht zwischen bonbons und
luftschutzkeller seit kriegsbeginn sind
wir mit einigen von ihnen in kontakt
jennifer gierke und naryn dogan haben
sie ihre geschichten erzählt
[Musik]
das ist meine zehn monate alte tochter
akira
wir sind aus aktiv ihr hergekommen nach
sieben nächten krieg
es war zu gefährlich in hartz iv zu
bleiben
du hast toll mitgemacht du hast toll
mitgemacht die zu deiner mama danke dir
aktiv
also gestern nach dem ersten
fliegeralarm hier dachte ich okay wenn
es noch einen fliegeralarm gibt packen
wir unsere sachen und bereiten uns
darauf vor wieder umzuziehen und das ist
heute passiert also fangen wir heute an
alle zu packen was wir haben und dann
sind wir jederzeit bereit ins auto zu
springen und richtung westen zu fahren
denn der osten der ukraine ist jetzt
nicht mehr sicher
ich wünsche meiner tochter dass sie in
frieden lebt in einem land ohne
verrückte nachbarn die sie eines tages
angreifen
dass sie in frieden und in harmonie mit
der welt leben
das sie kreativ tapfer und nett ist und
dass sie das süßeste mädchen der welt
bleibt
ich biete immer noch sprechstunden an
ich führe die beratungen für meine
patienten online auf anfrage durch
wie oft das möglich ist dass ist
natürlich unvorhersehbar in dieser zeit
weil die patienten unter besonderen
umständen leben
ich hatte einmal eine online sitzung mit
einer patientin und während der sitzung
gab es eine explosion
meine patientin erschreckte sich und ich
habe den explosionsknall auch deutlich
gehört
sie fragte mich andauernd haben sie das
auch gehört haben sie das auch gehört
es war als ob wir dieses grauenvolle
erlebnis gemeinsam durch leben was ganz
in der nähe passiert und de facto jedes
unserer häuser betrifft
hallo an alle ich bin alexander und ich
helfe den menschen in prag auf die
situation in kharkiv ist schwierig teile
der stadt sind zerstört menschen sitzen
in ihren kellern und haben angst
rauszugehen
jeden tag versuchen wir genug
lebensmittel zu verteilen
wir machen essenspakete und bringen sie
zu den leuten
fast 7000 menschen haben diese hilfe
schon erhalten
zum beispiel kaka r bereitet lawatsch zu
es ist ein typisches brot aus georgien
dafür nutzt er das hier
ein besonderer offen
wir helfen ihm und steuern den weizen
bei
jeden tag bereitet er vier bis
fünfhundert stück umsonst vor
die menschen können dann kommen und es
mitnehmen
[Musik]
wir sind in einem luftschutzbunker ins
netz geht
hier sind sehr viele menschen
wir sind in einer entbindungsklinik und
die menschen hier sind dazu gezwungen
ein oder zwei oder drei stunden in einem
luftschutzbunker zu sein
es sind besonders viele frauen die auf
ihrer entbindung warten
schmidt ski liegt im westen der ukraine
und ist damit sicherer aber heute früh
am morgen wurden drei städte im westen
der ukraine von russischen truppen und
von russischen fliegern angegriffen
die menschen sind jetzt glücklich weil
sie raus dürfen
und wir müssen jetzt auch raus weil der
alarm vorbei ist
jetzt ist es möglich raus zu gehen
mehr als zweieinhalb millionen menschen
sind inzwischen aus der ukraine geflohen
in deutschland sind offiziell knapp
110.000 flüchtlinge registriert
wahrscheinlich sind es aber noch viel
mehr vor allem in berlin kommen viele
ukraine an die stadt sieht sich an der
grenze der belastung aber auch die
hilfsbereitschaft ist groß aus berlin wo
man lässt
obama ist seit drei tagen in berlin sie
kommt aus odessa hat zwei kinder das
dritte ist unterwegs jetzt ist sie in
der praxis von natalia reicht diese per
ultraschall untersucht gianna ist sehr
in sorge um ihr kind nach der
anstrengenden flucht weg zu gehen ist
ihr trotz aller unsicherheit sehr schwer
gefallen mein arzt erklärte mir es ist
zu gefährlich für mich zu bleiben hätte
er das nicht gesagt wäre ich nicht
gegangen der vater des kindes ist immer
noch vor ort wie auch viele verwandte
wir sind jetzt in sicherheit und
immerhin die kinder haben das erste mal
wieder gelächelt
was das ungeborene angeht kann natalia
reicht die schwangere beruhige es ist
wohlauf die gynäkologin ist eine von
über 500 berliner ärztinnen und ärzten
die unentgeltlich die geflüchteten
behandelt viele schwangere betreut sie
bereits viele fragen seien gerade für
diese frauen aber noch nicht geklärt ich
habe keine informationen geben den
kliniken das ablaufen könnte wo die
frauen sich vorstellen können wer der
ansprechpartner ist wir rudern da so
ziemlich im moment noch allein um die
gesundheit der geflüchteten kümmern sich
mittlerweile auch die berliner amtsärzte
das erste große krone impfen in
zusammenarbeit mit der ukrainischen
botschaft trotz kurzfristiger
ankündigung die resonanz ist groß
offenbar haben sich die deutschen
regularien schnell herumgesprochen
ich bin hier für eine dritte bei und
texter impfung 2 harry schon ohne die
dritte impfung kann man hier vieles
nicht machen
es ist völlig okay eine dritte impfung
zu erhalten ich hatte bei den anderen
beiden in der ukraine auch keine
nebenwirkungen
doch nicht alle sind vorgekämpft manche
haben zudem nur den hier nicht
zugelassenen chinesischen impfstoff
erhalten viel aufklärungsarbeit für die
ärzte und freiwilligen helfer
also ich habe das gefühl die kinder sind
noch gar nicht geerbt bei den
erwachsenen
halb halb würde ich sagen immer
schwieriger wird dagegen die situation
am berliner hauptbahnhof gestern kamen
allein in den zügen knapp 9000 weitere
geflüchtete in die stadt trotz neuem
zelt vor dem eingang und wachsender
bettenkapazität bekommt die stadt immer
mehr probleme mit der unterbringung
wir sind hier im keller ähnlichen räumen
untergebracht worden ohne heizung und
komfort es war feucht alle die wir dort
waren sind jetzt wieder zum bahnhof
zurück gefunden
die angespannte lage zeigt sich auch auf
berlins messegelände kurzfristig
entstand diese note übernachtungs stelle
gleich 360 menschen kamen gestern nacht
berlins regierende bürgermeisterin
fordert mehr koordination durch den bund
zwar gebe es unterstützung aus anderen
bundesländern
das reicht noch nicht und wir gehen
davon aus dass wir jeden einzelnen tag
jetzt weitere über 15.000 menschen hier
haben die ankommen ich habe heute von
der europaabgeordneten des landes berlin
gehört dass eu-weit etwa mit sechs
millionen menschen gerechnet wird
berlins hauptbahnhof bleibt dabei einer
der zentralen anlaufadressen der
geflüchteten in deutschland dass der
zustrom bald nachlässt damit rechnet in
der stadt niemand
ja und um berlin zu entlasten wurde auch
in hannover ein drehkreuz für die
flüchtlinge aus der ukraine errichtet
und zugeschaltet aus hannover ist uns
jetzt der ministerpräsident von
niedersachsen stefan bei guten amt
hallo guten abend was ist denn zurzeit
die größte schwierigkeit bei der
versorgung der flüchtlinge
naja die größte schwierigkeit ist dass
wir nicht genau wissen mit wie vielen
menschen wie es wohl zu tun haben das
ist ja der große unterschied zu der
zuwanderung im jahr 2015 die in dem fall
aus dem süden kam jetzt kommt sie aus
dem osten aber der hauptunterschied ist
der dass alle diejenigen die zu uns
kommen erst einmal drei monate lang rein
rechtlich betrachtet als gäste hier sein
können auch überall im bundesgebiet sich
aufhalten können und sich nirgendwo
melden müssen und das ist etwas was uns
immer große praktische probleme bereitet
das ist ja auch zum ausdruck gekommen
was brauchen denn die menschen am
allermeisten
nach dem gespräch die ich mit
geflüchteten habe sind sie erstens sehr
gefasst also ich bin auf ungeheuer
tapfere gesprächspartnerinnen und
gesprächspartner gestoßen das muss ich
schon sagen und die erste frage war
eigentlich nicht was könnt ihr mir geben
sondern die frage war wann können die
kinder eingeschult werden was muss
passieren damit ich arbeiten können das
fand ich auch toll aber im übrigen gibt
es halt 1000 fragen die man braucht wenn
man irgendwo ankommt positiv ist derzeit
das wirklich viele auch ganz private
kontakte haben und da wird dann auch
über geholfen heute wurde ja nun doch
entschieden dass die flüchtlinge
möglichst bundesweit nach einem
bestimmten schlüssel verteilt werden sie
haben gerade gesagt sie wissen nicht
genau wie viele kommen werden aber auch
wie viele geflüchtete stellen sie sich
denn nun ein
na ja wir sind angewiesen auf prognosen
und da sind ja auch alles nur
schätzungen das sind unter anderem
zweifel davon ab wie lange dieser elende
krieg in der ukraine noch dauern wird
denn auch das ist mir sehr klar gesagt
worden in meinen gesprächen eigentlich
wollen alle so schnell wie möglich
wieder in ihrer heimat zurückkehren aber
sie wissen es ähnlich wir auch nicht und
müssen wir uns rüsten für einen fall der
im zweifel noch mit deutlich mehr
menschen verbundes die zu uns kommen als
dass beispielsweise vor sechs jahren der
fall gewesen ist der vorteil wiederum
auch das muss man sagen ist wir haben
damals natürlich eine menge gelernt und
diese erfahrung kompliziert zu starten
gerade frau gehört die fordert mehr
unterstützung koordination vom bund
fordern sie das auch weiter ein
na ja der bund tut sehr viel und ich
glaube die länder sind auch alle
hilfsbereit im moment sehe ich das
größte thema darin dieses rechtliche
problem das sich geschildert habe so
aufzulösen dass wir zu einem guten
praktischen system kommen das heißt dass
eine erfassung möglich sein wird und
dass wir auch die möglichkeit haben
relativ schnell den betroffenen zu sagen
für die erste zeit müsst ihr da oder
deren aufenthalt nehmen denn wir müssen
aufpassen dass nicht insbesondere die
großen städte überlastet werden so wie
sich das derzeit abzeichnet sondern dass
wir möglichst zu einer gleichmäßigen
verteilung kommen das klappt nie zu 100
prozent das wissen wir auch aus den
erfahrungen vor sechs jahren aber das
muss so gut wie möglich unser ziel sein
zum schluss noch was sagen sie denn zu
den angeblichen vermittlungsversuchen
von altkanzler gerhard schröder in
moskau
da weiß ich wahrscheinlich genauso viel
wie sie und wie die zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer aber wir alle wünschen uns
dass dieser krieg möglichst schnell zu
ende ist
wenn irgendetwas jetzt derzeit etwas in
diese richtung geht dann werden wir alle
sehr sehr froh also hoffen wir das beste
dank stefan bei
der gerne tschüss wer gehofft hat dass
sich russland von seinen maximal zielen
verabschiedet und ernsthaft zu
verhandlungen bereit ist der wurde
gestern nach dem treffen der
aussenminister bitter enttäuscht wir
haben die ukraine nicht attackiert sagte
da allen ernstes der russische
außenminister lawrow und das nach zwei
wochen krieg der in russland nicht so
genannt werden darf über lügen und
propaganda des kreml manuela konrad
die kriegspropaganda in den russischen
staatsmedien läuft auf hochtouren wie
sollen wir mit den bildern von
militärtechnik oder mit dem beschuss
umgehen das verstehe ich überhaupt nicht
verteidigung des friedens so heißt die
kindersendung in der einem mädchen die
bilder der zerstörung der ukraine
erklärt werden nicht russischer raketen
hätten das wohnhaus in kiew zerstört
sondern ukrainische staatspropaganda für
die kleinsten
die rakete ist dunkel farben ihre
invasions spur ist weiß charakteristisch
für einen raketenabschuss seitens
ukrainischer streitkräfte es ist immer
das gleiche narrativ das auch gestern
außenminister lavrov wieder bemüht
wir greifen keine anderen länder an wir
haben auch die ukraine nicht angegriffen
wie wir schon oft erklärt haben wurde
dort eine situation geschaffen die die
sicherheit der russischen föderation
direkt bedroht
nicht russland sei der aggressor sondern
die ukraine es sei kein angriffskrieg
sondern eine spezialoperation
russland müsse sich verteidigen in der
ukraine würde einen genozid an millionen
menschen stattfinden das ziel die
befreiung der ukraine von
dieser bande von drogenabhängigen und
neonazis in kiew die das ganze
ukrainische volk als geisel genommen
haben
die russische staatspropaganda läuft
ganz nach erprobter sowjetischer
tradition versetzung des westlichen
diskurses chaos stiften durch
desinformation putin beherrscht das
muster wie kein zweiter die kgb schule
hat ihn geprägt
gestern zur besten sendezeit im
russischen fernsehen in einer
diskussionssendung bezeichnen diese
lenski als narren auf dem thron und
geben ihm die schuld am krieg
du bist der hauptschuldige für dieses
blut du konntest und kannst diese
schlachterei stoppen
die nowaja gaseta eine der letzten
unabhängigen zeitungen russlands
erscheint heute mit leeren seiten und
mit einer erklärung warum sie nicht
neutral über die sogenannte
spezialoperation in der ukraine
informieren kann
besonders groß war das entsetzen über
den russischen bombenangriff auf ein
kinderkrankenhaus mit einbindung
stationen vor zwei tagen in mario pohl
dabei wurden nach ukrainischen angaben
zwei erwachsene und ein kind getötet 17
menschen verletzt seitdem verstrickt
sich die russische regierung in
widersprüchliche aussagen oliver klein
aus unserem faktencheck team hat sich
das ganze noch mal genauer angesehen was
sagt denn russland zu diesem angriff auf
ein krankenhaus also auf ein ziviles
ziel ja da gibt es ganz unterschiedliche
erklärungen von russischer seite die
sich teilweise auch komplett
widersprechen der russische
außenminister lawrow fort das spiel
gestern bei einer pressekonferenz gesagt
in diesem end bindungs heim so hatte das
genannt waren seit langer zeit keine
frauen kinder oder personal mehr also
die klicks sei gar nicht mehr in betrieb
gewesen sagt prof er rechtfertigt den
luftschlag damit dass in der klinik sich
kämpfer von diesen sogenannten soft
bataillon verschanzt hätten und er
bestreitet also gar nicht die
verantwortung überhaupt für diesen duft
schlag aber es gibt russische stellen
die diese aussage von laptop
widersprechen das
verteidigungsministerium beispielsweise
also die sagen die russische luftwaffe
hat absolut keine angriffe in der region
geflogen das hat igor korotschenko
gesagt ein sprecher des ministeriums
aber wir haben alle doch diese bilder
von den verletzten hochschwangeren
frauen gesehen
ja da gibt es wiederum eine erklärung
von der russischen botschaft in
großbritannien eine ziemlich zynische
erklärung wie ich finde die haben allen
ernstes bei twitter verbreitet und
behauptet die schwangeren frauen die man
dort auf fotos gesehen hat dass sein die
seien alle von ein und derselben
schauspielerin verkörpert worden von
einer ukrainischen bloggerin wir haben
uns diese fotos mal genauer angeschaut
und mit einer gesichtserkennungssoftware
analysiert tatsächlich ist da wirklich
eine ukrainische bloggerin unter den
opfern gewesen und dass es eben das
perfide der russischen propaganda nur
weil da eben eine bloggerin unter den
opfern ist wird gesagt dass wir alles
inszeniert
die frau war wirklich vor ort also die
war hochschwanger die wollte einfach in
der klinik nur ihr kind auf die welt
bringen und dann gab es eben auch noch
ein weiteres foto von einer frau die auf
einer liege liegt ja weg gebracht wird
verletzt auch hochschwanger und dann
sagt die russische botschaft das ist
auch diese frau ist auch von dieselben
schauspielerin verkörpert wurden wir
konnten nachweisen dass es eine ganz
andere person ist dank oliver klein ihre
recherchen kann man auch finden auf der
zdf heute app
zur russischen desinformation gehört
auch dem gegner vorzuwerfen was man
selbst vor hat deshalb beunruhigende
meldungen über angebliche chemische und
biologische waffen keine wichtigen
nachrichten und bilder aus der ukraine
zusammengefasst von gert anhalt
das dörfchen bischof gegründet vor über
500 jahren liegt eine autostunde
westlich von kiew zwischen weizenfeldern
und kartoffeläckern und hatte bis vor
kurzem noch knapp 3000 einwohner
das ist von bischof übrig nachdem die
russen es überrollt haben auf ihrem weg
in die hauptstadt und hinterließen die
überall tote zerstörung und
traumatisierte menschen in angst
meiner nichte cousine und oma haben in
diesem raum geschlafen sie sind am leben
aber alles ist auf sie gefallen
ein französisches fernsehteam begibt
sich auf eine lebensgefährliche reise
durch das kieler umland in dem die
russen sich zum sturm auf die hauptstadt
sammeln
ukrainische truppen und angehörige der
heimwehr wollen die angreifer mit
straßensperren und minenfeldern
aufhalten
beim letzten checkpoint vor der front
wird aus fernem kanonendonner plötzlich
gezielter beschuss
runter runter rufen die milizionäre und
das team muss um sein leben rennen
auch diese menschen konnten gerade noch
entkommen aus der reichweite russische
artillerie sie haben ihre häuser und
ihre habe zurückgelassen sind zutiefst
verstört und erschüttert sie haben den
angreifern in die augen gesehen
sie haben kein wort gesagt
sie waren sturm
standen da wie steiner
die heimat zerschossen existenzen in
trümmern lebensträume in scherben sind
sie ratlos und auch der geistliche der
bei ihrer rettung half kann dieser
prüfung keinen sinn mehr abgewinnen
es gab keinen grund uns anzugreifen wir
haben niemandem etwas getan sie wollten
eine zukunft in demokratie wenn die
russen die sowjetunion wieder herstellen
wollen dann sollen sie es in gottes
namen innerhalb ihrer eigenen grenzen
machen
durch die menschenleeren straßen kiews
halte an diesem sonnigen und eiskalten
morgen das rattern der rollkoffer auf
dem straßenpflaster wieder macht sich
eine familie auf die flucht
mittlerweile soll schon die hälfte der
einwohner ihre häuser und wohnungen
verlassen haben
wir tun was wir können um die
zivilbevölkerung zu schützen
aus unseren städten die der feind
zerstören will haben wir 100.000
menschen in sicherheit bringen können
mario pohl und wohl nur wasser bleiben
blockiert denn die russen halten sich an
keinen waffenstillstand
mario pohl liegt weiter unter schwerem
beschuss in den sozialen netzwerken
werden dazu diese bilder geteilt mitten
im wohnviertel tut sich ein meter tiefer
krater auf und alle fenster der
umliegenden gebäude sind zerborsten
ganz ähnliche aufnahmen sollen die
millionenstadt mehr pro zeigen die wurde
am frühen morgen ziel eines russischen
luftangriffs
aber auch mit den fortgesetzten
bombardierungen kann putins armee die
moral der ukrainischen verteidiger nicht
brechen immer wieder findet man im netz
auch szenen wie diese die das ende einer
russischen panzereinheit dokumentieren
soll
mit jedem rückschlag jedoch den die
angreifer erleiden wächst im westen die
angst dass sie bald zu noch schlimmeren
waffen greifen werden
[Musik]
die russische regierung hat verbotene
chemische kampfstoffe schon gegen ihr
eigenes volk eingesetzt und auch auf
britischem boden
sie haben das brutale assad regime
unterstützt das giftgas eingesetzt hat
wir wissen also aus erfahrung zu welchen
mitteln diese regierung zu greifen
bereit ist
und der westen kennt auch die russische
desinformations taktik
während sie gerne bilder wie diese
zeigen russische soldaten beim verteilen
von hilfsgütern
dichten sie den ukrainern exakt die
dinge an die sie selbst im schilde
führen aktuell geht es um den einsatz
von massenvernichtungswaffen
folgendes macht mir sorgen wir haben
inzwischen eines gelernt wer wissen will
was die russen vorhaben muss nur
hinhören was sie anderen vorwerfen ich
bin der präsident eines landes von
vernünftigen leuten ich habe selbst zwei
kinder
wir haben in diesem land keine chemie
waffen oder andere
massenvernichtungswaffen gebaut
derweil entrüstet sich präsident putin
gegenüber seinen militärs dass der
westen söldner aus der ganzen welt zum
kampf in die ukraine schicke und zwar
völkerrechtswidrig seinem
verteidigungsminister sagt er daher
werden leute zu ihnen kommen also
freiwillige die das nicht für geld tun
sondern die den menschen im donbass
helfen wollen nun dann können sie die
meinetwegen gerne dorthin schicken
16.000 bewerbungen sagt der minister
habe er schon erhalten vor allem aus dem
nahen osten
ob dazu auch die wilden horden zählen
die von putins tschetschenischen
verbündeten ktf in die schlacht geworfen
werden sagte er nicht mit der hilfe von
söldnern oder ohne auch in der dritten
kriegswoche stehen die zeichen weiter
auf eskalation
und in der ukraine ist für uns katrin
eigendorf katrin was hören sie denn aus
den belagerten städten wie mario pohl
oder kiew
die lage in mario pohl spitzt sich
weiter dramatisch zu es sind ja schon
jetzt
1582 menschen laut informationen der
stadtverwaltung bei russischen angriffen
ums leben gekommen die stadt ist soweit
umzingelt dass dort keine humanitäre
hilfe mehr ankommt dass die menschen
dort riskieren zu verhungern über kurz
oder lang ist kommen auch nicht mehr
genug medikamente an es sterben viele
menschen einfach auch weil sie
lebensnotwendige medikamente dort nicht
erhalten die bilder die wir sehen auch
von menschen die schnell in
massengräbern begraben werden müssen das
sind die bilder die putin haben möchte
das sind die bilder mit denen er die
ukrainische bevölkerung
demoralisieren will das ist
psychologische kriegsführung und ist
zeigt sich an diesem 16 tag des krieges
doch auch die strategie es ganz gezielt
darauf anzulegen zivile opfer hier immer
mehr zivilisten in angst und schrecken
zu versetzen das sieht man auch bei dem
letzten angriff auf die stadt nie provo
auch wieder ein kindergarten getroffen
wurde man rechnet jetzt hier auch die
leute hier mit ski damit dass die
luftangriffe überall im land stattfinden
können und wie das zentrum für
strategische kommunikation der ukraine
veröffentlicht hat soll angeblich heute
abend noch belarus auch in diesen krieg
eingreifen das ist eine bis jetzt
unbestätigte information
aber das wird sich zeigen ob das nun
wirklich ist das würde den krieg
natürlich noch einmal deutlich weiter
eskalieren
schluss noch kurz in den verhandlungen
mit russland ist ja kein durchbruch in
sicht woraus schöpfen denn die menschen
hoffnung
zu schöpfen einerseits hoffnung durch
ihren präsidenten seelands behält hier
jeden tag und auch heute wieder
ansprachen an das volk gehalten das ist
wirklich die zentrale figur der
präsident der hier die leute zusammen
hält aber ich denke sie schöpfen auch
hoffnung daraus dass sie sehen mit
welchem gegner sie es hier zu tun haben
mit welcher gnadenlosen brutalität putin
hier vorgeht sie wollen nicht unter
einer russischen marionettenregierung
leben die leute und ich glaube
vielleicht kann man es nicht hoffnung
nennen aber widerstandsgeist auf jeden
fall der kommt daher vielen dank katrin
eigendorf und alles gute in der ukraine
wer kann wladimir putin stoppen die
rolle chinas ist da besonders wichtig
doch mit kritik an russland hält sich
die volksrepublik zurück gleichzeitig
will man den westen nicht verärgern
schließlich mit china weiter geschäfte
machen über den chinesischen balance-akt
ulf röller
in den chinesischen hauptnachrichten
findet der krieg in der ukraine aktuell
kaum statt die berichterstattung widmet
sich den verhandlungen zwischen den
russen und der ukraine in der türkei
chinas bevölkerung soll glauben russland
wolle den frieden
am besten wäre es wenn beide seiten
weiter friedensgespräche führen würden
ich hoffe dass sie bald das problem
lösen können
die achse moskau peking stellt sich
gegen die alte westlich geprägte
weltordnung seit hieß machtantritt haben
sich beide präsidenten
38 mal persönlich oder virtuell
getroffen beide eint die feindschaft
gegen die usa china will sich als
friedensstifter inszenieren und sorgt
sich auf der heutigen abschluss
pressekonferenz des volkskongresses um
die weltwirtschaft
die weltwirtschaft kämpft bereits mit
den folgen der epidemie die fans
sanktionen treffen alle länder und
gefährden die wirtschaftliche erholung
weltweit
chinas macht elite will den frieden
unterstützt aber russland darin sieht
sie keinen widerspruch
wollen das vertiefen in china ist uns
deshalb unser korrespondent ulf röller
zugeschaltet auf den westen nicht
verprellen und gleichzeitig demonstrativ
an der seite der russen stehen wie gut
gelingt china dieser spagat
natürlich ist dieser spagat eine
diplomatische übung die durchaus china
wehtut aber man muss gleichzeitig auch
sagen dass der chinesische präsident
trotz vielleicht mancher ungemach
mancher dinge die nicht so läuft wie er
das für richtig hält an seiner position
bisher nichts ändern will er wird weiter
an der seite von russland loyal stehen
wichtig für die chinesische macht elite
ist es dass die heimatfront steht dass
also die chinesen hinter der politik der
staatsregierung stehen dafür sorgt die
nationale propaganda also hier heißt es
immer wieder amerikas schuld von den
gräueltaten die wir auch eben wieder in
den berichten gesehen haben der
russischen armee erfahren die chinesen
überhaupt nichts sondern eben sie
erfahren dass ihr land versucht frieden
zu stiften und international natürlich
verprellt shipping mit dieser politik
den westen aber die chinesen denken auch
solange der westen sauer ist aber nicht
wirklich auch sanktionen oder china
fallen vor allem europa sanktionen über
china verhängt weil sie mit täter mit
den russen sind solange das eben nicht
passiert bleibt shipping da relativ cool
und macht sie ist um mit dem bild zu
bleiben in diesem spagat bequem das ist
jetzt eine neue feste allianz gegen den
westen die alte militärische supermacht
russland seit an seit mit der neuen
wirtschaftlichen supermacht china
ja ich glaube schon dass es das ist also
auf der anderen seite haben wir die
autokraten und diktatoren die doch
ziemlich angst vor der demokratie haben
und zusammen stehen und auf der anderen
seite haben wir die freie welt die sehr
sehr geschlossen jetzt ist für die
chinesen ist das ein nachteil also sie
haben das gefühl dass dieser krieg den
putin ausgelöst hat die nato wieder
belebt hat makro der französische
präsident hat ja gesagt sie sei hirntot
und nun stets aus chinesischer sicht
sehr sehr stark da das ist ein problem
für die chinesische politik weil sie
eigentlich über die letzten jahre immer
wieder versucht hat europa und amerika
zu spalten aber china denkt in sehr sehr
langen linien und hier hört man immer
wieder in china dass sie sagen na wer
weiß wer in zwei drei jahren
amerikanischer präsident es vielleicht
court donald trump wieder und vielleicht
ergibt sich daraus wieder eine chance
als auch hier gilt man wartet ab
verharrt im spagat und hofft dass die
dinge aus chinesischer sicht sich besser
vielen dank und
dann blicken wir noch auf die alte
supermacht die usa in washington ist für
uns immer tee wissen präsident joe biden
hat ja heute russland vor dem einsatz
von chemiewaffen gewarnt ist das für
beiden eine rote linie
also er hat bewusst glaube ich diese
brachte rote linie vermieden weil er
eben nicht will dass man ihnen dann
nachher auch daran messen kann je
nachdem wie amerika auch so einen
vorgehen russlands reagieren wird aber
er hat sehr klar gemacht russland würde
dafür einen hohen preis zahlen und das
wird hier als signal gesehen dass es
dann amerika und seine verbündeten mit
anderen massnahmen antworten könnten als
mit sanktionen und waffenlieferungen was
genau das sein könnte es natürlich
völlig offen man denkt hier vielleicht
wird man dann an die vereinten nationen
herantreten dann doch eine
flugverbotszone durchsetzen wenn es
irgendwie möglich ist vielleicht sogar
unbemannte waffensysteme drohnen liefern
amerikanische drohnen an klinische
streitkräfte die palette ist vorhanden
aber eines will joe biden um jeden preis
vermeiden ein direktes eingreifen in
diesem krieg weil er sagt das würde in
den dritten weltkrieg führen kein
direktes eingreifen welche möglichkeit
sehen die usa überhaupt noch um diesen
blutigen krieg zu stoppen
ehrlicherweise wenig man glaubt dass
putin sein minimalziel ausgegeben hat
und das ist die komplette zerstörung der
ukrainischen streitkräfte mit
katastrophalen befolgen dann eben auch
für die zivilbevölkerung und dass er
sich mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit auch
nicht alleine von den sanktionen durch
die sanktionen und auch durch die
waffenlieferungen und die militärischen
schlappen die er dort erleidet in der
ukraine
beeindrucken lässt man setzt darauf dass
in seinem umfeld personen sind das
werden eh weniger die oligarchen sein
sondern eher aus dem sicherheitspersonal
aus den sicherheitskräften den
geheimdiensten die bereit wären
vielleicht ihn zu stoppen
möglicherweise ihn aber auch nur zu
überzeugen dass er einen ausweg finden
muss vielen dank elmar theveßen
ja viele menschen wollen helfen wenn
auch sie die menschen in der ukraine
oder auf der flucht unterstützen wollen
dann können sie spenden an das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine bahn.de
65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
auch unter spenden zdf de oder im zdf
text auf seite 8 190
und die spenden summe liegt bisher bei
über 95 millionen euro
das war es von uns am tag 16 des krieges
gegen die ukraine und ein schnelles ende
ist leider weiter nicht in sicht mehr
informationen jetzt gleich auch bei zdf
heute live oder später im heute journal
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]